hello everyone and welcome once again to
the penultimate round of this year's
chess olympiad it is
versus notre dusato of the game
everyone's been waiting for as both of
them have had an incredible tournament
uh gucash uh 16 years old abus 17 years
old also the reigning world rapid
champion uh this is definitely uh the
clash to watch both of them have
defeated fabiano caruana in this
tournament with the black pieces uh
lucas started with eight out of eight
and abdusatrov started with five out of
five
uh then he slipped a little bit he lost
one game but then he quickly bounced
back so both of them having an
incredible tournament and this is uh the
match that we all wanted to see and it
does not disappoint in terms of uh in
terms of the the moves played so let's
check it out it is uh
quite quite a thing to spectate uh and
also i don't know if you guys are
interested in this fide announced today
that we already know the host for 2026
olympiad and it will be hosted by
uzbekistan so just in case you were
wondering so bulkash has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 uh c4 we have e6 knight to
f3 and d5 going for the queen's gambit
declined
and now knight to c3 and bishop to b4
everyone's favorite era goes in defense
and uh we already mentioned a few videos
ago bishop g5 and c captures on d5 are
the main ideas here also e3 is very
popular
but queen the a4 check is what most
players are trying out nowadays so queen
a4 knight to c6 and now pawn to e3
we have castles uh and now bishop to d2
the the knight is no longer pinned and
now uh comes the the incredibly rare
move here d captures on c4 is the
main idea also a6 is very popular but
abu sathrov plays a5 and uh it's not new
but it has been played only a handful of
times so a3 challenging the bishop we
have bishop characters bishop characters
and now knight to a7 so abdusatrov gives
up the bishop pair so what will he gain
in return we have queen back to c2
and now there is a game where d captures
on c4 was played in a game between
alexis mironov and evgeny alexev in 2021
that ended in a draw but here we have b6
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game so here b3
strengthening the c for pawn and the
bishop to a6 putting the bishop on this
very very strong diagonal putting
pressure on c4 now comes a for stopping
any b5 ideas in the future and not
knight to e4 going after the dark square
bishop uh but just bishop back to b2
ghoukish prefers to have his bishop pair
intact uh knights the c6 and now bishop
to a3 by putting pressure on the rook on
f8 we have knight to b4 and now bishop
captures on b4 messing up abdusatro
spawn structure here uh and now uh pawn
captures here at some point you are
expecting either c5 or maybe in the
future this pawn will go to c5 then
maybe you will have
a pass pawn on a4 ready to be pushed
forward so here bishop to d3 putting
pressure on the knight also just
threatening to win a pawn here so knight
to f6 here you could decide to go for
the very committal f5 that defends the
the knight and well then you you can go
for something like bishop captures if
captures attacks the knight and then it
comes to e5 and while this is playable
uh you know it's it's not everyone's cup
of tea so after bishop to d3 knight back
to f6 uh abdusatro prefers to keep the
position intact and now we have castles
by ghoukish uh c5 now uh the pawn has
stayed on c7 for far too long uh d
captures on c5 b captures and now uh
goku does have a pass pawn on a4 now uh
but abdusatrov has all of this immense
pressure in the center so uh
pawn to e4 yeah that's how he decides to
play it it even means that uh abdul
satyar can win guke a light square
bishop for example if you go for this
capture and bishop captures which was
played in the game you could capture it
but after queen captures uh the knight
here feels much much stronger than the
bishop on a6 you cannot play bishop b7
the queen is already beautifully
centralized on e4 and you know that the
rooks are coming on the d file knight is
coming to g5 then maybe some rook d3 to
h3 g3 action is is possible so it's hard
to say if the the bishop will be able to
fight the the knight on f3 so instead of
instead of capturing rook to a7
uh you could also move the queen maybe
you want to
put the rooks and double up rooks on the
d file but abu satro has an idea uh
knights to e5 now going for knight to c6
with with the beautiful fork and now
queen to d6 just attacking the knight uh
rook hdf one uh sorry rook f31 attacking
uh defending with a tactic basically now
if queen captures we can just open up a
discovery with check and pick up the
black queen so knight captures an e for
queen captures and only now rook to d8
and this is how abdul satorov grabs hold
of the d file and what can um
the problem is uh if there are any uh
new new players watching if you go for
rook 8 to d1 which is something that you
want to do there's always this nasty
queen captures and rook captures and
white gets checkmated when you want rook
captures and e1 will be checkmate so for
the moment lukas cannot claim the d file
for himself so queen to f3 uh this
prepares rook to d1 but also puts some
pressure on the f7 pawn for the moment
it is defended by the rook here but it's
it's a very nasty pressure so queen back
to c7 and now rook eight to d1 uh we
have rook eight eight now preparing to
capture uh with the rook if the rooks
get traded off and this is exactly what
happens rook captures rook captures and
now comes rook to d1 offering a rook
trade and now uh best for uh for uh
abdusatrov is to just trade rooks and
create some breeding room for his king
with a move like h6 however in the game
he plays rook the c8
and this is not a big big problem
because now the position is completely
winning for gucash and it's such a such
a tricky move to make
that i will ask you guys to pause the
video here so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this uh absolutely
gem of a move that wins the game for
gookash while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the move
gookash played and that is queen to g3
but that there is a far stronger move
and that is queen to h5 so whoever found
queen to h5 congratulations you are a
true true master of the game uh point is
that after queen to h5 there's no
defense against rook to d7 and then you
will have a triple attack on f7 and
there that's just it there's no move
that black can play there there is
absolutely no more black and blade it
doesn't matter if you play rook f8 still
just rook d7 and we're attacking f7
three times it's completely winning uh
the only move you can make is maybe f5
because now okay if rook to d7 now the
queen no longer defends the knight so
maybe we can capture the knight but we
just defended with f4 and that's it uh
now rook to d7 is coming and uh
there is no way to if you play rook d8
we can simply trade then queen captures
and then you no longer have control over
the f7 square so that's the problem and
if you play queen e7 rook the d7 attacks
the queen and queen eight you offer a
queen trade then we happily trade here
and now just play rook a7 and good luck
saving this bishop you have to play rook
bishop to c8 and now this bishop is
stuck here for the rest of the game the
pawn is blocking it in the knight and
the rook control this square so the
bishop can never go anywhere and well
it's merely a matter of pushing the pawn
and
that's it these pawns are on dark square
so even if white wants white can just go
go collect it there's nothing black can
do about this so this would be
completely winning for gurkish however
after rook the c3 like i said he played
queen to g3 which is similar
but it allows abdusatrov to
sort of uh sort of get back into the
game and if you're wondering why not
just look to d7 right away well of
course queen captures on e5 and then
queen captures an f7 check king h8 the
queen now protects against checkmate and
you are adjusted down a piece still
white is what is uh not lost here or
anything uh but there's just no good way
to continue playing this so like i said
queen g3 and now we have ponte h5 a much
needed move for abdusatro as now
backrank issues are no longer an issue
h3 and now rook to d8 offering a trade
of rooks we have rook capture 78 queen
captures and not knight to d3 so
basically uh this is what lukis found
when he decided to play queen to g3 if
this wasn't so appealing and this is
incredibly appealing with perfect play
this is probably a clean win for white
uh he would have found that uh basically
an instant win now the problem is these
spawns are on dark squares you're gonna
play queen e3 and you're gonna start
collecting pawns and there is nothing
abdusathorov can do about this so h4 we
have queen to e3 and now comes bishop to
b7 finally the bishop is reintroduced
into the game uh but at what cost
black's position is on the verge of
being completely lost the situation on
the clock is a gookash has some 20
minutes abdusatrov has
11 minutes on the clock and there are
eight more moves to be made to be to
reach time control so upon to f3 agukish
is in no rush to win the pawn we have
queen to d6 and now king to f1 goku
starts bringing the king into the game
pawn to e5 and only now does he capture
on c5 knight captures on c5 uh we have
bishop to c8 as the bishop on b7 is
hanging and now we have kinked the e1 we
have bishop to f5 now grabbing hold of
some very important squares you can see
that the pawn covers c3 bishop covers d3
and this uh so if the black queen can
somehow infiltrate white's camp could be
uh very nasty but now lucas does uh what
he planned uh for the entire game he
created a fast pawn now he starts
pushing it pawn to a5 it is the only
move that wins the game for him and he
of course plays it situation on the
clock eight minutes
uh abdusatra of six minutes on the clock
we have queen to c7 now abu sathu has to
organize some sort of a defense against
the pass pawn and just pawn to a6 there
seems to be no stopping the pawn we have
bishop to c8 now comes knight to d3 this
is again incredibly uh uh this is
perfect play i mean just giving up the
pawn like this shifting attention to the
e5 pawn
and uh you know played with with such
elegance knight to d3 uh the problem is
now if you defend the pawn for example
f6 then a7 the pawn is defended on a
dark square on a7 you have a light
square bishop this is resigns so here
you have to trade the bishop captures
now comes queen captures an e5 offering
a queen trade and of course um and no
direct cannot afford a queen trade he
has to keep the queens on the board and
try to complicate the matter as uh the
king is somewhat open so we could
deliver some checks uh so luke is not in
a rush to push anything he just plays
knight to c5
uh prevents the queen from infiltrating
queen to a5 now hoping to get some queen
a2 action in and king to d1 uh and now
comes queen back to d8 with check if you
go for queen a2 and try to you know
harass the white king this way we can
just play queen eight check pick up the
pawn and now okay you can play queen to
b1 queen a1 with check but we're just
gonna bring our king all the way up and
uh still the position is winning for
white so here abdul satrav goes queen
back to d8 with czech and now king the
c2 bishop to c8 getting the bishop out
of harm's way and now knight to e4 we
have bishop to e6 and now comes king to
b2 and this king to beat you is a move
that will uh will that gookash will
regret for a very long time here it's
just too easy for the black queen to
start harassing the white king
you have to play queen to d6 and then
yeah
you force a queen trade now queen to a8
is not as potent because the king can
start marching up the board you are
ready to start pushing your pawn this
would be the way to go but both of them
are very low on time and uh it's just an
extremely complicated position so king
the b2 was played now abdusatrov just
goes queen a8 he's ready to start
checking the white king knights to c5
and now queen to a3 with check now
gukesh is in 12 minutes abdu sutra of 21
minute and he plays king the b1 uh this
is the the second mistake that he makes
uh or maybe not a mistake maybe a lesser
move would be a better term uh but with
king to c2 it's still possible for him
to push this uh position after king to
b1 uh it is no longer possible not just
the g6 and the glucose is without a move
the problem is you can never capture on
e6 which was the whole point because if
you capture uh abu satrav can just start
checking king the c1 queen captures and
c for king to be two now queen captures
on e6 and this is a dead draw so instead
after g6 we have king to c2
brings his king to c2 with a tempo
wasted but now queen a2 check
queen to b2 and now bishop to f5 with
check knights the e4 blocking and now
not cap not of course trading but queen
back to a7 keeping the queens on the
board and now we are ready to continue
not with that obviously but we are ready
to continue harassing the
the white king so came to d3 and now it
will be a problem getting uh away from
this pin with the queen covering this
diagonal and the bishop covering this
diagonal so here queen to g1
and now queen to c2 we have queen back
to c5 and queen to d2
there is nothing for
for either of them to do the position is
objectively a draw however here about i
think i was it was around at this point
uh is uh when both of them realized that
pragernanda has won his game and now
abdusatrov has to play for the win
otherwise india wins against uzbekistan
so he can't just afford to repeat moves
so queen g1 king the c sorry not queen
king to c2 and now queen to a1 with king
to d3 and now queen back to g1 so abdu
sutter of making quick moves but he's
making sure that uh the the game is not
settled in a draw queen to e2 and now
queen back to a7 we have queen to e3
offering a queen trade queen to a2 now
going for the b3 pawn and now king d
uh four now the queen defends the pawn
but now gurkis gives up the g2 pawn he
has to give up something he unpinned and
now he can start pushing for the win
queen captures on g2 we have knights to
g5 and now pawn to f6 kicking away the
knight here and even though queen the e8
looks um like it's a very interesting
after king to g7 there's just no way to
end this properly queen to f7 check even
king to h6 and now white is the one who
will be struggling to uh to save the
game there's just no good move here so
instead after king to g7 we have queen
e7 check king to h6 and now knight the
f7 check we have king to h5 and now king
to c5 so this game is nowhere near a
draw both players are now fighting for a
win queen captures on f3 queen captures
on f6 and now queen to e3 with check
king captures on b4 and the bishop
captures an h3 so after 65 moves uh it's
uh
it's equal material a bishop against the
knight and with uh
anything just
you know completely possible so knight
to e5 now going after that g6 pawn and
of course queen to d to check king b5
and now bishop to d7 with check hoping
that the knight capture so we can trade
here and here you have to play king to
b6 and the game continues however king
to c5 was played and now it becomes a
little bit easier for satarov to push
this for more than a draw queen to e3
check we have king to b4 now bishop to
f5 defending the pawn and consolidating
his position we have queen h8 check
queen to h6
of offering a queen trade uh gucash uh
declines the trade because if you trade
here then just king captures and even
though uh okay it's equal material the
past pawn on h5 is just much too close
it will be a win for abdusathorov so
queen to d8 was played and now comes
queen to g7 and this is the moment that
gurkish will regret for a very very long
time he was extremely low on clock he
had some 30 seconds
or no he had three seconds when he
played the move he had some 33 seconds i
believe he he almost lost some time here
he had like three seconds on the clock
he played knight to f3 and now the game
is completely lost it is completely
winning for abdusatrov and you i mean i
could ask you to pause the video and i
might even do it because uh
i don't know no i'm not going to even
ask you to post the video because of
course you guys see what happened uh the
knight has been blundered away just
queen the b7 check was played andy was
in this position on move 72 that gurkish
resigned the game and his perfect run uh
has ended after so many wins only one
draw against bamidarov uh he finally
loses a game to notre because in the
penultimate round of the video chess
olympiad
by blundering a piece so uh
i mean this is unimaginable such a run
to be ruined by uh by blundering a piece
like this but the tension was so high i
mean uh you if you've seen the video of
the two of them playing now they were
both shaking for the better part of the
game their knees were just you know uh
going crazy it was uh
you could see that both of them were
incredibly nervous as so much
depended on on their game but uh after
queen to b7 check gucci resigned and not
rebecca abdul sathrov takes the win for
team uzbekistan on board one which is
just incredible incredible especially
since gucci had that a beautiful win
with queen to h5 but yeah he resigned
because once the king moves of course
queen captures on f3 you're up a piece
there's no point in playing this
uh but yeah uh uh gukesh will be very
very sad that in this position where and
abdusatro played rook the c8 he did not
find queen to h5 and the only reason
like i said is that he saw that queen to
g3 was winning and with perfect play it
is winning and he just probably uh
didn't expect that there is more than
one winning idea here
but queen to h5 like we've shown is the
instant resigns
uh so a tough break for a good but uh a
great break for for nothing break up
saturday and steam uzbekistan uh here
are the scores over the board the
gurkhas lost to abdusatta of yakubu
withdrew against nikhil sarin pragananda
defeated cinderella and adiban drew his
game against wakidov so that means india
2 and uzbekistan drew their match 2-2
and these are the standings of defeated
chess olympiad after the penultimate
round so you can check it out uh team
uzbekistan and team armenia are tied in
first place with 17 points then with 16
points we have india two india and
united states of america and then with
15 points we have netherlands spain
england germany and the moldova so
anything can still happen in the final
round it's going to be uh completely
intense until the very end we'll see
what happens
in the final round uh so that's the game
i hope you guys enjoyed it really really
a wild one uh the the most expected game
from the olympiad and it did not
disappoint it did disappoint goku she
was in it was definitely a heartbreak
for him but i mean
just an incredible game to to witness uh
so yeah once again really hope you guys
uh enjoyed it uh
uh
and ended uh you know a little bit of
info about the standings uh i would like
to thank natarajan rangasami who boobies
joshua hadley uh prasanna krishnamurti
and michael calvera for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the olympiad
uh until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day